WELCOME TO THE EIGHT APRIL
FOURTH ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HERE. ENOUGH.
NOTING THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
WE'RE GONNA START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
I A N..
SEE THAT MR MAIENSCHEIN IS IN
THE AUDIENCE LIKE TO WELCOME HIM
UP I THINK OF A COUPLE BILLS ARE
GOING TO PRESENT ON.
WHAT WE START?
WITH.
WELL AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SECONDS
SEX IS ON CONSENT I DON'T THINK
YOU WANT TO PULL THAT.
.
WHAT WE START WITH A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETY THREE ENJOYS A
DO PASS AS AMENDED?
THE AMENDMENTS SEARCH REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT TO APPLY ONLY IF
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
TO SUNSET. TO CHANGE REPORT TO
MODIFICATION TO MAKE
NOTIFICATION CONTINGENT ON THE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVING FUND A
WOULD YOU LIKE TO START.
BEFORE AGAIN I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS AT THAT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF I AND MY STAFF
WORKED OUT TO CLARIFY AND REDUCE
THE STATE WORKLOAD AS YOU JUST
ENUMERATED. AT IT IS ESTIMATED
THAT ONE IN FIVE WOMEN SUFFER
FROM MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS THESE DISORDERS CAN
INCLUDE ANXIETY DEPRESSION OR
EVEN. POSTPARTUM PSYCHOSIS AND
CAN AFFECT WOMEN DURING
PREGNANCY AND WHEN WITHIN THE
FIRST YEAR AFTER GIVING BIRTH
AMONG AMONG MOTHERS AND POVERTY
NEARLY FIFTY PERCENT WILL BE
AFFECTED BY ONE. OR MORE
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
MANY STATES INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
DO NOT HAVE SUFFICIENT TOOLS AND
RESOURCES IN PLACE TO SCREEN OR
TREAT WOMEN FOR MH DISORDERS AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION. IS SEVERELY
LACKING.
AFFECTS THE S. A. B. EIGHTEEN
NINETY THREE WILL REQUIRE THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO APPLY FOR FEDERAL
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
THOSE OF FUNDS FUNDS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE TWENTY SIXTEEN BRINGING
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION OUT OF THE
SHADOWS ACT BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY.
DEPARTMENT MUST NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE OF ITS PLANS FOR
UTILIZING THE FUNDS IF AWARDED.
THIS CAN INCLUDE PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS INCREASE
SCREENINGS TELEHEALTH SUPPORT
FOR BOTH PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS
STUDIES TO IDENTIFY AND CLOSE
GAPS AND TREATMENT
AND MORE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN. NINETY THREE AND
EMPHASIZES THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDS AND RESOURCES I
HAVE JESSICA WALTERS WHO SAT ON
THE CALIFORNIA TASK FORCE. ON
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH.
BOTH THE FEDERAL BRINGING POST
PARTUM DEPRESSION OUT OF THE
SHUTTLE'S ACT IS PART OF THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY CURES ACT
WAS FUNDED AND.
HARSHA WILL BE DISBURSING FIVE
MILLION IN GRANTS TO STATES.
TWO ESTABLISH IMPROVE OR
MAINTAIN PROGRAMS TO TRAIN
PROFESSIONALS TO SCREEN A SEVEN
ENTRY MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS.
COUNTY MITCHELL THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WITH A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH TASK FORCE. AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE IMPORTANT ROLE
CDP H. IS ADDRESSING MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH FOR LOW INCOME
WOMEN THROUGH PROGRAMS
COMPREHENSIVE PRENATAL SERVICES
BLACK IF IT HEALTH HOME VISITING
AND OTHER THINGS SUCH TO THAT
NATURE. AND A STATEWIDE PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN NOTING THE
FUNDING WOULD BE NECESSARY TO
GIVE THIS PROPER ATTENTION TO
ITS NEEDS A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY
THREE REQUIRES CD.
P. H. TO APPLY THESE FUNDS
FEDERAL FUNDS IN REPORT BACK ON
HOW THE FUNDS WILL BE USED.
TO THE LEGISLATURE OF NOTE
TWENTY TWENTY MOM WAS THE
SPONSORING ORGANIZATION OF THE
FEDERAL BRINGING POSTPARTUM
DEPRESSION OUT OF THE SHUTTLE'S
ACT.
AND WE ARE SO HAPPY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY THE GREAT
THINGS WE CAN DO WITH OUR
MOTHERS IN THE COMMUNITY.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MEDICARE MEMBERS
GILLIAN ADAIR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVING A
FILE ON THIS MISSION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
CNN WHAT CHUCK CLOSE MISTER
SCHECK BAKE YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWO NAME THREE
IS JUST ONE STEP OF MANY THAT
NEEDS TO BE TAKEN FOR CALIFORNIA
TO EFFECTIVELY CARE FOR ITS
MOTHER'S. SUFFERING FROM
INTERNAL MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU AND I SOON AS WE.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE WILL TAKE
THAT UP FOR ABOUT.
I'M. YOU HAVE.
WE PRESENTATION ON A. B.
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE.
AB TWENTY SIXTY TWO IS ON
CONSENT I'M SURE YOU DON'T WANNA
PERCENT ON THAT. AND.
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING ON AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WHICH IS
ON SUSPENSE BUT I UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE SOME WITNESSES HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY SO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE THAT ON
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE
MADAM CHAIR A. B. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR IS A SUSPENSE.
CANDIDATE WHICH WILL ESTABLISH A
TWO YEAR PILOT PROJECT PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO FOSTERING
KINSHIP CAREGIVERS. VIA POST
PLACEMENT COACHING WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE CARRIED BIRTH MICHELLE
EVANS FROM THE MCGEORGE SCHOOL
OF LAW LEGISLATIVE AND PUBLIC
POLICY CLINIC.
TO TESTIFIED SPORT ANSWERING
QUESTIONS THAT YOU'RE COMMITTEE
MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
THE MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHELLE
EVANS AND I AM A LAW STUDENT AT
MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW
PARTICIPATING IN THE LEGISLATIVE
AND PUBLIC POLICY CLINIC.
I AM ALSO A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I FAN. SOCIAL
WORKER FOR NEARLY TWENTY YEARS
AND I'VE ALSO WORKED AS A CASE
WORKER IN A FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
AND IN MY EXPERIENCE CURRENTLY
RESEARCH HAMLEYS RECEIVE A
MINIMUM OF TWELVE TWELVE HOURS A
FEW POLICEMEN TRAINING. AND
EIGHT HOURS OF ANNUAL TRAINING.
WHOSE PLACEMENTS
AND HOWEVER THE LEVEL OF SUPPORT
THAT THEY RECEIVE VARIES GREATLY
FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY WITHOUT
SUPPORT IMMEDIATELY UPON
POLICEMEN AND A ROCKET SUPPORT
WHEN CHALLENGES ARISE. FAMILIES
ARE OFTEN FORCED TO MAKE A
DIFFICULT DECISION TO ASK FOR A
SEVEN DAY AT REMOVAL OF THE
CHILD FROM THEIR HOME. ADDING TO
THE TRAUMA THAT THE CHILD HAS
ALREADY EXPERIENCED UPON REMOVAL
FROM THEIR OWN HOME AND ALSO
ADDING TO THE DISSATISFACTION OF
THE FAMILIES PARTICIPATING IN
THE SYSTEM.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM TO
IMPLEMENT POST'S POLICEMEN
COACHING SUPPORT TO SELECT
KINSHIP AND FOSTER FAMILIES. AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF COUNTIES
PARTICIPATING FAMILIES WILL BE
ASSIGNED A COACH AT THE OUTSET
OF POLICEMEN. SETTING FAMILIES
UP FOR SUCCESS.
DESIGNATED KINSHIP IN FOSTER
FAMILY COACHES WILL DEVELOP AN
ONGOING PLAN FOR SUCCESS UPON
PLACEMENT PROVIDE RAPID SUPPORT
WHEN PROBLEMS DO ARISE THEIR
OUTPLACEMENT.
AND WILL PREVENT THE NEED FOR
SEVENTY NOTICES AND EMERGENCY
REMOVALS.
THIS WILL IMPROVE RESOURCE
FAMILY TRAINING SUPPORT AND
RETENTION AS WELL AS STABILITY
AND PERMANENCY FOR CHILDREN ALL
IMPORTANT ELEMENTS. OF A
CONTINUING CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM ACT.
WE ARE CURRENTLY RESEARCHING
FUNDING WE NEED TO WRAP IT UP
I'M SORRY EVERY WITNESS GETS TWO
MINUTES SO OKAY GREAT.
SO I SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL I SUSPECT.
THANK YOU IT BEFORE WE GO NEXT
WITNESS OF IT'S OKAY WOULD LIKE
TO ESTABLISH FORM WHICH.
IMPORTANT.
MOMENT IN TIME.
MA'AM SECRETARY.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRO.
CALDERON. CARRILLO.
CHAO.
EGGMAN.
PHONE.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
GARCIA.
HIS IRAN.
OBERNOLTE. QUIRK HERE GREATEST.
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR NEXT
WITNESS
SPIKE. A CAKE MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CARRIE FOR. I'M ALSO
STUDENT AT MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF
LAW PARTICIPATING IN THE
LEGISLATIVE AND PUBLIC POLICY
CLINIC I AM A CO SPONSOR OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
SECTION ONE OF AB SEVENTEEN NAY
FOR CREATES A PILOT COACHING
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
SUPPORT TO RESOURCE FAMILIES
WHICH WILL ASSIST THE STATEMENTS
EFFORTS.
TO RETAIN FOSTER PARENTS.
AN INCREASE PLACE FOR THE
STABILITY FOR FOSTER CHILDREN
SECTION TWO OF AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WILL PROVIDE
RESOURCE FAMILIES WITH ACCESS TO
AVAILABLE STAY IN COUNTY.
SUPPORT SERVICES ORALLY IN
WRITING AND ON DEPARTMENT
WEBSITES.
BUT THESE PROVISIONS AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
SUCCESS.
BY IMPLEMENTING FAMILY BASED
CARE FOR ALL CHILDREN AND
SUPPORT. THE SEATS IT WILL
SUPPORT THE STATE'S INVESTMENT
IN THE CCR.
WITH THE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
PROVIDED BY AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOR AN INCREASE IN PLACE THAT
STABILITY AND PERMITS HE WOULD
ALSO PROTECT THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT. IN FOSTER PARENT
RECRUITMENT RETENTION AND
SUPPORT.
WE HAVE BEEN AYE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES REGARDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND FUNDING AT
THIS BILL. WE ARE USING THEIR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ALONG WITH
SUGGESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT TO SAVE COSTS FOR
EVER PRACTICAL. AND ENSURE
EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROVISIONS OF EACH AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR.
THEY'VE ALSO BEEN RESEARCHING
POTENTIAL FUNDING SOURCES TO BE
UTILIZED BY COUNTIES FOR IT THAT
COACHING PILOT PROGRAM.
THESE EFFORTS WILL CONTINUE
DURING THE SUSPENSE PROCESS.
I SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
PLEASE.
MELISSA AND MO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND
SUPPORT. THINKING.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
WHICH I TOOK CLOSE AT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF REQUEST YOUR
FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION AND OF
COURSE THIS BILL GOES ON SUSPEND
SO. THANK YOU. WE WELL THOUGH
TAKE UP IF I HAVE A MOTION.
ON.
A MOTION FOR MISTER BIGELOW
SECOND FROM MISTER QUIRK ON YOUR
A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY THREE.
AND THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL SAM THANK YOU.
NEXT UP.
IS. MISS WHAT LIMON I WANNA
REMIND FOLKS WE'RE.
.
STARTING SLOW TODAY SO I'VE.
BEEN GRACIOUS SPED OUT OF THE
WITNESS SAYS ARE.
LIMITED TWO MINUTES EACH TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH AND
I'M WE DO TRY TO KEEP THE
COMMENTS FISCAL IN NATURE I'M
I'M NOT REALLY TOUGH ON THAT BUT
IT IS THE POLICY COMMITTEE HAS
ALREADY HEARD THE POLICY ASPECTS
OF THESE BILLS SO. WE DO TRY TO
KEEP THIS ARM TO THE FISCAL
ISSUES.
MISLIM OWN IS ARE GOING TO
PRESENT ON A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION GREAT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX IS A SMALL
CHANGE TO PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR WORKING MOTHERS IN
TWO WAYS ONE ADELINE ST STATUE
WITH FEDERAL LAW SAFEGUARDING
THIS IMPORTANT PROTECTION
AGAINST ANY CHANGES TO THE ACA
AND TO. IT HELPS TO REDUCE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER THAT
PREVENTS WOMEN FROM CONTINUING
TO BREAST FEED UPON RETURNING.
TO WORK BY ENSURING THAT THERE
IS A PRIVATE AND CLEAN SPACE
AVAILABLE TO EXPRESS MOVE THE
BILL REST MILK THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK
IN A SECOND BY MISTER OBERNOLTE.
.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIRMAN
SHABAKA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WITH THE
SPONSORS OF AB NINETEEN SOME
EFFECTS OF KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF AND THANK THE. COMMITTEE
AND STAFF AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU CAN GO THERE
BUT IF YOU TALK TO THE TABLE IF
YOU PREFER.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED TO A.
B. NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WE HAVE
BEEN IN DISCUSSION WITH THE
SAMOANS RESET OUR OUR.
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION FOR POLICY REASONS
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE.
ADDITIONAL.
MEMBERS OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FIVE.
DIRTY QUESTIONS I THINK MISTER
BIGELOW HOUSE ONE. YES ON
BUSTAMANTE.
LOOKING THROUGH YOUR BILL THERE
SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE BIT OF.
TREPIDATION WITH SOME FOLKS AND
WE JUST HEARD ONE OF THEM
AND THEIR REAL CONCERNS ABOUT
THE MANDATE ISSUE COULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT A LITTLE BIT
FOREST.
AND KIND OF EXPLAIN THAT.
IT IS IT IS A QUESTION ON
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS A MANDATE
SO THAT YOU KNOW THAT I CAN HAVE
ACTUALLY MACHEL.
ADD TO THIS BUT I DO WANT TO
SEE THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY
CURRENTLY IN FEDERAL STATUTE AND
SO THE GOAL IS TO HAVE IT IN
STATE STATUTE AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT SO IT
WOULDN'T CHANGE WHO.
TO COMPLY WITH THIS I JUST MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY THE
FEDERAL LAW WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT AND WE WOULD BE DOING AT
THE STATE LEVEL.
AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT.
.
THE CHANGES THAT WE ARE.
REQUESTING THAT THE BILL WOULD
NOT.
CHANGE THE FACT THAT.
EMPLOYERS WOULD STILL NEED TO
MAKE A REASONABLE EFFORT SO THAT
REASONABLE EFFORTS STANDARD
STILL. APPLIES CURRENTLY AND
WITH. THE PROPOSED CHANGES.
SO FOR CLARK.
ARE YOU WILLING ARE YOU STILL.
THE WORK WE.
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON WAY OUT
OPPOSITION DEFINES.
COMMON GROUND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE A CONVERSATIONS. BECAUSE
I HAPPEN TO AGREE WITH YOU ON.
PERSONALLY DON'T AGREE WITH
HAVING WOMEN.
NURSING AND BATHROOM STALLS.
WHAT WE DO OUR BUSINESS?
OKAY I AM GLAD THANK YOU THINK
YOU'RE HOT THE EYE IN THE AND
IT'S APPRECIATED RAVING THAT
THIS IS WHAT IT IS IT'S A IT'S A
HEALTH. AND ISSUE I THINK WE
WANT YOU KNOW KIDS BABIES TO BE
HEALTHY IN OUR COMMUNITY THIS IS
BIGGER AND SO I THINK WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE IN CALIFORNIA.
UMMAH CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR MOTHERS WHO ARE
BREASTFEEDING AND FOR THE KIDS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
HEALTHY ON AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ENCOURAGING BREASTFEEDING
WHICH IS A GOOD THING.
I AGREE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND BUT WE
NEED A COUPLE MORE MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE TO SHOW UP AND SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND.
.
BUT THAT I'M CALL AND TELL
EVERYBODY.
HERE UP I WOULD ASK TO TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR ON YOUR
BILL WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU
AND ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO BE A CO AUTHOR. AS A CO
AUTHOR THINK YOU THINK MS LIMON.
MISS COMING AT ALL.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AB TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WHICH WILL MAKE THE CALIFORNIA
CHILD DEPENDENT CARE EXPENSES
CREDIT REFUNDABLE.
SO THAT LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES CAN BENEFIT FROM THAT
THIS UP CHILDCARE. TO ASSIST
THEM WITH THEIR CHILD CARE
EXPENSES THE CRITIC CURRENTLY
ALLOWS TAXPAYERS.
WITH INCOMES BELOW ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO REDUCE THEIR
TAX LIABILITY BY CERTAIN
PERCENTAGES FURTHER ELIGIBLE
CHILDCARE EXPENSES IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE STATE MADE
THE CREDIT NON REFUNDABLE DUETO
BUDGET SHORTFALLS. AND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT FAMILIES WITH
INCOMES LESS THAN FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS RECEIVE NO BENEFIT FROM
THE CURRENT CREDIT.
SINCE IT BECAME NON REFUNDABLE
NINETY PERCENT OF THE CREDIT WAS
CLAIMED BY FILERS WITH INCOMES
BETWEEN FIFTEEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT.
THAT IF YOU'RE EARNING FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BUT IN CONTRAST WHEN
THE CREDIT WAS REFUNDABLE.
SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT OF THE MONEY
WAS CLAIMED BY FILERS WITH
INCOMES LESS THAN FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO IF THE POOREST OF THE
POOR THAT ACTUALLY COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS. OUGHT TO MEET
THEIR BASIC EXPENSES.
WE KNOW THAT CHILDCARE IS THE
SECOND HIGHEST COST AND.
SO RESPECTFULLY IT ANDERSON
THIS IS GOING ON SUSPENSE BUT I
THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PERCENT THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO FAMILIES IN MY COMMUNITY.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS MICHELLE
STILL APARTMENTS KEY FROM THE
CHECK CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE SOBRE
MINSKY CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
THIS BILL TO MAKE THE CHILD
INDEPENDENT EXPENSES CREDIT
REFUNDABLE ON SO THAT LOW INCOME
WORKING FAMILIES ARE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS HELP ON TO
DEFRAY THE. RISING COST OF
CHILDCARE.
RIGHT NOW THE CREDIT EXCLUDES
THOSE WHO ARE MOST TRUGGLING ON
TO PAY FOR CHILDCARE EXACTLY THE
FAMILIES THAT WE SHOULD BE
HELPING MOST.
UNDER AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE A
LOW INCOME FAMILY COULD RECEIVE
A REFUNDABLE CREDIT OF UP TO ONE
THOUSAND FIFTY DOLLARS WHICH IS
ONLY A SMALL PORTION OF WHAT
CHILD CARE COSTS. BUT WOULD MAKE
A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES AND BUDGETS OF FAMILIES
WHO ARE LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK.
RESEARCH REVEALS THAT REFUNDABLE
TAX CREDITS NOT ONLY INCREASE
FAMILIES INCOMES BUT ALSO
IMPROVE CHILD HEALTH AND
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES AND SAVE
MONEY. TO FOR THE STATE IN THE
LONG RUN. FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES EVEN A SMALL INCREASE
IN FAMILY INCOME IS ASSOCIATED
WITH HIGHER EARNINGS IN
ADULTHOOD.
AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE MAKES A
SMALL STEP TO MAKE THE TAX CODE
MORE EQUITABLE CURRENTLY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES PAY A LARGER
SHARE OF THEIR INCOME IN STATE
AND LOCAL TAXES AND HIGHER
INCOME FAMILIES.
GIVEN THAT WOMEN WOMEN OFTEN
BEAR THE BRUNT OF CHILDCARE
COSTS THIS BILL ALSO ADVANCES
GENDER EQUITY AND CLOSING THE
WOMEN'S WEALTH GAP.
BUT AB TWENTY FORTY THREE IS A
LONG OVERDUE POLICY THAT WILL
HELP WORKING FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN AYE AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AS A BUILDING COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
JESSICA BARTOLO WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
DONNA STARED AT THE CHILD CARE
ALLIANCE OF LOS ANGELES OUR
BOARD IS CONSIDERING.
POSITION ON THURSDAY BUT WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A REALLY STRONG
MEASURE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YES FINANCES OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL DO IT SUBSTANTIAL GENERAL
FUND REVENUE LOSSES.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
ESTIMATES REVENUE LOSSES OF
FORTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIS REVENUE LOSS
ASSUMES AN ANNUAL LEGISLATIVE
APPROPRIATION SUFFICIENT TO
COVER THE BILL'S COST EACH YEAR.
I WE ALSO KNOW THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD.
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS HAVE NOT
YET BEEN DETERMINED BETTER
EXPECT.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS IF NOT.
CHUCK CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE WHEN IT COMES UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
I AM WORRY AND I'M SORRY BECAUSE
I I. KNOW SOMEBODY IS NEXT ON
THE LIST BUT WE'RE GONNA GET LET
MISS REYES DO HER.
.
BILL AS A COURTESY.
IN THIS RACE CAN BE PRESENT AB
TWO ZERO ZERO ONE AND ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWO THOUSAND ONE STANDARDIZES
ALLIANCE AND CODIFIES THE DUTIES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOME EDUCATION
NETWORK.
THEIR CONTRACTORS AND PROVIDERS.
FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME EDUCATION
NETWORKS OFFER PROMISING
PRACTICE MODEL FOR THE STATE TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY.
OF FAMILY CHILDCARE OPTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA MOVE WILL HOWEVER
EXISTING LAW LACKS CONSISTENT
ADMINISTRATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
NETWORKS.
SO TOOLS USED TO MAKE QUALITY
ASSESSMENT MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE TO. TO FAMILY CHILD
CARE HOME SETTINGS
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL IS DONNA SNEER INJURE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT.
RELATIONS FOR THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER AND NINA
BOOSTING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHILD DEVELOPMENT
JUST ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION AND WE REALLY
FEEL THAT THE ALIGNMENT AND
STRENGTHENING OF THESE PROGRAMS
IS IMPORTANT. AND I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING ALSO THINK YOU AND
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL THIS BILL IS REALLY
STREAMLINING CURRENT BEST
PRACTICES IT'S CODIFYING IN LAW.
IT REALLY WILL PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE SUPPORT FOR THESE
PROGRAMS SO WE REALLY DO FEEL
LIKE THIS IS A VERY GOOD MEASURE
TO MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
AND I M. A PUBLIC POLICY MEMBER
AND THAT PUBLIC POLICY COMMITTEE
AND DIRECTOR OVER CENTRAL REGION
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR THE EDUCATION OF YOUNG
CHILDREN AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
FINANCE CURRENTLY DOESN'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH IMPLEMENTING THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL ARE MINOR AND
OBSERVER.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
QUIRK.
A SECOND BY.
MISTER CHOW THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK VARIABLE.
ALRIGHT WE NEED A COUPLE OTHER
PEOPLE. TO GET HERE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
.
I DO ANNOUNCED THOUGH THAT A. B.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX BY MUSLIM
MON DOES GET OUT ON.
.
AT B. ROLL CALL WITH.
MISTER BIGELOW IN MISTER
OBERNOLTE VOTING AYE.
AND MR FUNG NOT VERY.
MISTER GLORIA.
MR LAWYERS PRESENT NAME ON AB
TWENTY ONE OH THREE AND ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
IF FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE A THREE IS
WATCHING CLOSELY SOBBING JUST
EXTREMELY BRIEF BY ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT THIS BILL WILL DO THREE
THINGS ONE IT WILL. ESTABLISH A
MINIMUM NUMBER OF HOURS FOR
TRAINING FOR CONCEALED CARRY
PERMITS.
SECONDLY IT REQUIRES US
APPLICANTS FOR SUCH PERMITS TO
DEMONSTRATE SAFE HANDLING
PROFICIENCY ON A FIRING RANGE
AND LASTLY AMENDMENTS TO AB
TWENTY ONE OH THREE REQUIRE
LOCAL LICENSING AUTHORITIES TO
DEVELOP SPECIFIC BY FIRE
PROFICIENCY STANDARDS. AND MAKE
THE STANDARDS AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC I HEARD YOUR COMMENTS
BEFORE MEDI CHAIRED THE FISCAL
IMPACT AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE
REPORT ARE MINOR AND OBSERVABLE
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
WITH ME THIS MORNING I IS
ROSEMARY ISHIKAWA.
WITHOUT WHOSE THE VOLUNTEER
LEADER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AS YOU CAN SEE THE
GALLERY A NUMBER OF OTHER
SUPPORTERS AND VOLUNTEERS WHO
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT. OUT IF I
MAY.
YES I JUST WANT TO REMIND THE
WITNESSES PLEASE START BY
STATING YOUR NAME.
ROSEMARY YOSHIKAWA I'M WITH THE.
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER MOMS DEMAND
ACTION.
WE ARE IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
.
AMENDING THE LAW TO STATE THAT
AMENDING THE STATE LAW TO
REQUIRE LIVE FIRE TRAINING FOR
CONCEALED CARRY WOULD
MEMORIALIZE AND PRESERVE A
POLICY THAT CALIFORNIA SHERIFFS
AND POLICE CHIEFS HAVE ALREADY
ADOPTED. AND WANT ADDING A LIVE
FIRE TRAINING REQUIREMENT INTO
STATE STATUTE WOULD ENSURE THAT
THIS COMMONSENSE REQUIREMENT.
CONTINUES TO BE CONSISTENTLY
APPLIED ACROSS THE STATE. THANK
YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
HI DOMINIC TOMORROW HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA
HERE IN SUPPORT.
DENY SAID TELUS WITH MOMS AND
ACTION EVERY TIME FOR GUN
SAFETY.
AND INDIVISIBLE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OTHER SUPPORT IF
NOT.
OPPOSITION.
REMEMBER TO STATE YOUR NAMES
AND.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES AS THE
CHAIRS.
FOR EACH PRESENTER.
OF THE TO THEIR CITY UP HERE
THAT'LL BE NAMES AND POSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TEMPORADAS
REPRESENTING DOES CALIFORNIA AND
A CERTIFIED CCW INSTRUCTOR IN
THE STATE.
IN MULTIPLE COUNTIES.
SINCE NINETEEN OH EIGHT WHEN
THE CCW PROCESS WAS ESTABLISHED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE
HAS NOT BEEN ONE SINGLE INCIDENT
WHERE A CCW HOLDER HAS.
BEEN CHARGED OR CRITICIZED FOR
BEING.
UNWISE IN THEIR USE OR FOR LACK
OF TRAINING.
THE IT THROUGH THEIR CLASSES IN
WITH THE USE OF A FIREARM.
UNDER ILLEGAL CCW.
THE PHYSICAL ASPECT OF THIS IS
THAT IS NOT BEING CONSIDERED IS
THAT NOW EVERY SHERIFF IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO
HAVE TO. REDO THEIR.
CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
INSTRUCTORS.
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO SEND ALL
THAT INFORMATION OUT ALL
INSTRUCTORS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO.
RE DO THEIR THEIR THEIR OF
CURRICULUM AND SUBMIT THEM FOR
APPROVAL. NOW.
THAT MIGHT NOT SEEM LIKE AND
EXPENSE TO A LOT OF FOLKS BUT
THE FACT IS THAT THE. STATE
AUDITOR.
DATA ON AUDIT OF MULTIPLE
COUNTIES AND FOUND THAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO DO WHAT THEY WERE DOING AS OF
RIGHT NOW THIS WILL PUT A BURDEN
ON A LOT OF COUNTIES.
HERE IS THE FACT.
THIS IS ALREADY BEING TAKEN CARE
OF AND DOES NOT NEED ANY
ADDITIONAL.
LAWS OR REGULATIONS TO FIX
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT A PROBLEM.
THE ONLY TIME THAT CCW A
INSTRUCTORS DO NOT.
I'LL OFFER LIVE FIRE TRAINING
IS WHEN THEY KNOW THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE OFFERING
CLASSES TO OUR VERY WELL OF
VERSED IN THE USE OF FIREARMS.
THERE ARE NAVY SEALS RETIRED
THERE ARE.
DELTA OPERATORS RETIRED THERE
ARE MORE SOCCER OPERATORS
RETIRED THERE OF VETERANS
RETIRED THERE ARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO NO
LONGER SERVE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHO WOULD BE REQUIRED.
TO PROVE THAT THEY KNOW HOW TO
SHOOT A GUN. AFTER THEY HAVE
ALREADY GONE THROUGH MORE
TRAINING THAN. EVERYBODY PUT
TOGETHER.
POSSIBLY BE REQUIRED TO DO.
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THIS
A SEEKING UP ANSWER TO A PROBLEM
THAT DOESN'T EXIST THAT'S WHY WE
ARE STRONG OPPOSITION WE HOPE
YOU WILL CONSIDER THOSE.
FISCAL.
ASPECTS.
FOR THE RECORD IN REVIEW
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND
IN THE INTEREST OF BREVITY WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION ALL ECHO WITH
MY COLLEAGUES HERE SAID THIS IS
A SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A
PROBLEM. WE ARE PRESENTED NO
EVIDENCE THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT THERE IS A LACK OF TRAINING
AMONG CCW HOLDERS CURRENTLY IN
THE STATE. AND THIS WOULD PUT A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
SHERIFF'S IN ISSUING AUTHORITIES
TO REDO AND RESEARCH I'LL
INSTRUCT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHERS.
WISHING TO ADDRESS OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FLY.
MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
BUT WILL HAVE TO HOLD THAT
BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE.
MEMBERS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
YES BUT I'M MISTER VICE CHAIR I
WOULD JUST NOTE FOR THE RECORD
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WHOSE MEMBERS WILL
BE THE ONES HAVING TO IMPLEMENT
THIS IF IT'S MADE IT TURN INTO
LAW.
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION OF THE COMMITTEE
WOULD KEEP THAT IN MIND AS YOU
CAST YOUR VOTES LATER.
YOU VERY MUCH WHEN WE HAVE ON
THE
MEMBERS.
WE WILL
TAKE ACTION
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
MR LOW.
THE YOU HAVE AB NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN WOULD YOU LIKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT. AT
AB NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN WHICH
MAINTAINS INTEGRITY OF THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS BY
PROHIBITING I PAID SIGNATURE
GATHERERS OUT. OF.
BY THE SIGNATURE I RATHER THAT
AS THIS IS AN AGGRESSIVE
SIGNATURE GATHERERS OF PROCESS
IN WHICH WE SEE.
DAY IN DAY OUT WE'RE NOT WE GO
TO THE FARMER'S MARKET OR THE
STORES.
THIS LEADS
MISLEADS RESIDENTS INTO SIGNING
PETITIONS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
NOT NECESSARILY ENDORSED.
THIS I COULD BILL AGAIN
MAINTAINS AND TIRED OF THE
MISTER PROCESS BY ELIMINATING
THE INCENTIVE FOR PIZZA OR
TOGETHER IS TO APPROACH
INDIVIDUALS. AGGRESSIVELY.
A SPREADING MISINFORMATION A
COSTS ARE MINOR AND WITH ME
TODAY MILLIONS HUBRIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FICTIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
MAY CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WERE IN SUPPORT WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD. REVERTED BACK TO
THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THAT
CALIFORNIA'S INITIATIVE PROCESS
WE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT MINOR
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE COSTS WHICH
WE AGREE WITH AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHERS
PRESENTERS TO PRESENT MR LOW.
BUT ARE THERE ANY OTHERS WISH
NOT TO SMOKE IN.
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
ANOTHER MORNING ORGANISED IN ON
THE KILL EM ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
OUR CONCERN IS THAT.
OUTLYING SIGNATURE PAYMENT ON A
PER SIGNATURE BASIS WILL MAKE IT
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO ADDRESS THEIR
GRIEVANCES DIRECTLY WITH
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE IT WILL MAKE
IT AND TOO EXPENSIVE TO DO A
RECALL OR AN INITIATIVE AND
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO DO A
REFERENDUM. IS OUR CONCERN IS
NOT ONLY THE POLICY REASONS FOR
THE CHECKS AND BALANCES BUT THE
SMALLER ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE
ABLE TO AFFORD TO TO PAY ON THE
STRUCTURE BECAUSE OF THE STRICT
TIME FRAMES THAT ARE IN PLACE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MOVE
AROUND.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND WE HAVE THIS
I CAN.
NO FILE.
DO YOU LIKE TO CALL.
STRICTLY AS VERY.
WHEN WE HAVE.
MEMBERS.
HELLO.
WILL.
CONSIDER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISS WEBER
.
GOOD MORNING. THIS WEBER HOW
YEAH I'M GREAT HOW ARE YOU
MICHAEL AUTHOR HOW ARE YOU.
A I'M HERE TO MOVE AND THEY'LL
THANK YOU WE'RE.
I SHOULD SAY A WORD OKAY.
I DON'T WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT WE ARE PASSING A
PRESENTATION FOR TWENTY ONE
THIRTY THREE IT WAS AT TIMES IT
HAPPENS CLEAR CASE HAS THE GOOD.
MEMBER OVER HERE MADE A MOTION
EVEN THOUGH WHICH WHILE I KNOW
YOU AND I SAID I SAID TO PUT
TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE OF THAT
HAVE BEEN GOOD HOME.
CLICK SLOW.
AND DON'T I WASN'T FAST ENOUGH I
AM SO SORRY BUT WE ARE WE ARE
FOR THE RECORD WORKING.
IT WE ARE DOING TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY NINE
HERE TO PRESENT THIS BILL THAT
RECOGNIZES THE HUMANITY. OF
WOMEN AND THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY RESTORES
DIGNITY TO INCARCERATED WOMEN
AND REDUCES FURTHER TRAUMA BY
ONE PROHIBITING MALE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS FROM BEING
IN VIEW OF OR PAT DOWN SEARCHING
WOMEN. WHO ARE INCARCERATED OR
ENTERING INTO AN AREA WHEN
CARSON RATED WOMEN ARE IN A
STATE OF UNDRESS SUCH A SHOWER
ROOMS AND BATHROOMS?
THE BILL ALSO HOLD CORRECTION
OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE ENSURE THAT
DOCUMENTATION IS SUBMITTED WHEN
WOMEN ARE PET SEARCHED OR SEEN
IN A STATE OF UNDRESS BY A MALE
GAUR.
THE COSTS ARE MINIMAL TO THE
STATE SINCE THIS WOULD PUT INTO
LAW.
SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS
ESTABLISHED BY THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS AND CDC OUR POLICIES
THIS BILL PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT
OF PUBLIC SAFETY IT HAS AND HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE HUMANITY
OF THE WOMEN BEHIND BARS AND AND
MOVE TOWARDS COMPASSION AND
TREATMENT. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
IS BILL DUPLESSIS WELL BEHALF OF
THE HASHTAG CUT FIFTY.
GERMAN MEMBERS BILL DUPLICITY
REPRESENTING A CUT FIFTY.
.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY IS A
COMMONSENSE MODEST APPROACH.
I DO A PROBLEM THAT'S ACTUALLY
BEING ADDRESSED THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES ARE SIMILAR BILLS
THERE'S ONLY CONNECTICUT
KENTUCKY GEORGIA.
MARYLAND LOUISIANA AND AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
ALL OF WHICH SEEM TO BE.
GAINING.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TO GOOD GOOD
COMMON SENSE MAJOR NOT ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DO YOU HAVE OTHER PRESENTERS
DEL.
IS ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO RISE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SAM NUNN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
AND A SECOND.
MISTER.
.
QUIRK OFFERED IS THE MOTION AND
ALL SECOND THIS AS A CO AUTHOR I
AM PLEASED TO STAND WITH THIS
BILL.
WHAT WE LIKE TO CALL AND SAY
THAT IT'S OUR ON AND A ROLL
CALL?
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE THAT VERY
GETS OUT ON ANY OR ALL CLUB
THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU AND I DO NEED.
SOME COMMITTEE MEMBERS STORM
PRECIOUS.
MISS EGGMAN MISS FRIEDMAN.
MR GARCIA.
MR.
BROUGH.
AND.
I REALLY NEED EM. UM.
BUT HE GRATES SHOW I'VE
NONETHELESS.
.
BUT I THINK WE NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I HAD TO GET SOME THESE BILLS
OUT.
I'LL MISS EGGMAN GREAT.
GREAT WE'LL GO AHEAD THEN WE
HAVE.
A MOTION AND A SECOND ON A. B..
TWO ZERO ZERO ONE BY MISS RATES
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND ON AB
TWENTY ONE OH THREE GLORIA LIKE
IT'S OUT ON OF THE ROLL CALL. WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN LOW THAT
IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
AND THERE IS ONE MORE BILL WHERE
WE KNOW MISTER GREAT BUT I HAVE
A BILL AS WELL SO I'LL GO AHEAD
AND TURN IT BACK OVER TO THE
NEXT YEAR.
VERY MUCH.
MADAM.
MAKING HER WAY TO.
THE CALL STEP BY STEP.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB NINETEEN NO THREE
WOULD PROHIBIT GUN BUY BACK
PROGRAMS FROM DISTRIBUTING GIFT
CARDS TO RETAILERS THAT
POSSESSIVE FIREARMS OR
AMMUNITION AMMUNITION DEALERS
LICENSE.
THIS MEANS PEOPLE.
AND GUN BUYBACK PROGRAMS
WOULDN'T BE GETTING BASICALLY A
GIFT CARD TO GO PURCHASE
ADDITIONAL GUNS ARE AMMUNITION.
AYE AS NOTED THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS A. B. NINETEEN OF THREE
HAS A NEGLIGIBLE FISCAL IMPACT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THERE'S.
FOR.
ARE THERE ANY IN THE AUDIENCE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
NINETEEN A THREE.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO FILE.
WE WOULD LIKE ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
MISTER QUIRK AND MISS.
IT'S MADE THE MOTION TO SEGMENT
SECONDS.
THIS BILL GETS OUT ON OF THE
ROLL CALL.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR MISTER GRAY.
MR GRAY.
WE'RE READY FOR YOUR BILL
PRESENTATION.
WE ARE GOOD AT I'M GO AHEAD AND
KEEP THE COMMITTEE GOING FOR
FIVE MORE MINUTES MISTER GRAY
DID TELL ME THAT HE WAS GOING
TO.
IT COULD BE NINE FORTY FIVE
BEFORE HE GOT HERE THAT
SUPPORTING GIVEN THAT FIVE
MINUTES COURTESY TO.
I.
INTRODUCED AS WELL.
THAT'S NOT BAD AT THE CLOCK ONLY
SAYS EIGHT. THIRTY RIGHT NOW.
THE REAL THAT CLOCK LEGO.
SOMEBODY'S TRYING TO FOOL US
YEAH.
YES IN FACT I WILL TAKE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MISTER
QUIRK MOVES MENACE.
EGGMAN SECONDS AND.
WILL YOU. PLEASE.
CALL THE CONSENT COUNTER.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIX EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FIVE NINETEEN OH NINE
NINETEEN TWENTY NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE NINETEEN NINETY FOUR.
TWENTY FIFTY TWO TWENTY SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY EIGHTY TWENTY EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY NINE TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX TWENTY ONE NINETY
EIGHT TWENTY TWO. TWENTY TWO OR
FOUR TWENTY THREE OH NINE TWENTY
THREE THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWO.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY SEVEN.
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN TWENTY NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE OH TO.
THEY CANNOT GET OUT ON A ROLL
CALL ON MADAM SECRETARY BUTTE
CALL OUT THE BILLS THAT HAVE
BEEN MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FOUR SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TO EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX
NINETEEN OH FOUR NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY ONE.
NAKED NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT. TWO THOUSAND FIVE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY TWO THIRTY FOUR
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN TWENTY
THIRTY NINE. TWENTY SIXTY ONE
TWENTY SEVENTY TWO TWENTY
SEVENTY EIGHT. TWENTY NINETY
FOUR TWENTY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
ONE THIRTY THREE TWENTY ONE
THIRTY SIX TWENTY ONE FIFTY
SEVEN TWENTY ONE SIXTY ONE.
TWENTY TWO FIFTY THREE TWENTY
TWO FIFTY FOUR TWENTY TO SEVENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO EIGHTY THREE.
TWENTY THREE FIFTY TWENTY THREE
FIFTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR SIXTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE AND
TWENTY FIVE OR SEVEN
BUT SHE WAS
.
ONE.
THIS IS.
COMPANIES
.
GEN
I LIKE TO GET INTO THAT RIGHT
NOW.
THERE'S.
VERY.
NOT.
YEAH.
THE
.
ANYTHING.
WELCOME IS FRIEDMAN.
I DO WHEN I'M OUT I DID I.
DID NOT WELCOME OUR NEW CHIEF
CONSULTANT JAY.
AND ARE EDUCATION CONSULTANT NOW
NATASHA SO WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE.
FUNDS WERE WAITING ON MR GRAY
WE'RE GONNA GIVE HIM I TOLD HIM
NINE FORTY FIVE.
WERE GIVEN THREE MORE MINUTES
RIGHT
ONLY A REAL ASTEROID BRIGHTNESS.
ROY YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
WHAT'S THE LOWEST PAID JOB.
I'M. MATURE Y. LOS ZETAS BICU.
THERE IS NO.
SO EVERY.
HOWEVER.
WELL I KNOW THERE'S ONLY.
STATE.
JURY LEVEL.
RIGHT DIFFERENT TRACK.
THAT'S ANOTHER.
SECRETARY.
I CERTAINLY.
SELECT.
WHAT'S YOUR.
ACCORDING.
ALRIGHT I'M I I DID GIVE.
I DID COMMIT TO MISTER GRAY THAT
I'D WAIT TILL NINE FORTY FIVE AT
NINE FORTY TO HIS STAFF SAID HE
WAS FIVE MINUTES OUT.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN MAKING
PEOPLE WAIT SO UNLESS.
.
I I WOULDN'T SUGGEST SOMEBODY
PRESENT THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS.
THAT PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE.
YOU WANNA PRESENT.
WHAT LET'S CHECK WITH MR GRAY IF
YOU CAN GET HIM BY TEXT TO SAY
THAT'S OKAY I'D BE HAPPY TO HAVE
USED PRESENT MISTER GALLAGHER?
THE CREATOR OF THE BILL
.
ON THE EARLY.
IN THIS.
.
THEY'RE SUPPOSEDLY ON THE
ELEVATOR WE WILL GIVE THEM ONE
MINUTE IF THEY ARE NOT HERE HE
CAN PRESENT NEXT WEEK
ALRIGHT HE HAS PLENTY OF TIME TO
PRESENT THIS IN THE FOLLOWING
WEEK SO WE'RE GONNA HOA. GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE COMMITTEE NOW